(slow jazz music)
- You get your hair done,
you can't be touched.
You're just, you're on
point for at least 48 hours.
The queer community needs a safe space
to get haircuts
and that's part of the
reason why I'm here.
My name is Dez Marshall,
I'm a barber.
I work in Brooklyn, New York.
The barber shop I work at
is called The Gamesman.
It's kind of an institution here
in downtown Brooklyn.
The owner, Frank, has been here
for over 50 years.
- (unintelligible)
- The clientele has been a lotta
men who work in the neighborhood.
It's a lot of lawyers, a lot of judges,
other types of businessmen.
I kinda throw a wrench into all of that.
(laughs)
(upbeat jazz music)
I mix it up a little bit.
My clientele is mostly queer, trans,
gender nonconforming, folks of color,
non-folks of color.
For the most part,
my clientele is the LGBTQ community.
- I think, with
barbershops, it's difficult,
as a woman, to walk in.
It can sometimes just
feel like a boys club.
- It's nice to feel like
you can let your hair down, (laughs)
or just cut it off.
- I think I'm building a
bridge in different ways.
Can you be here at five?
3:30? I got you.
For queer folks,
for trans folks,
for gender nonconforming folks,
hair is very important.
You keep it really crisp, or
- Yeah, crisp.
- more rounded?
Got you.
Well you need a barber
that you feel comfortable to talk to about
how you want to look,
what's that vision that you have,
someone who can execute it,
but also do it in a way that
they're not gonna be judging you
throughout the whole process.
See how it's kinda growing out like that?
- I want to keep it ...
- Up?
- Yeah.
- Got it.
- I get to spend my day
with other queer folks
in a space that, you know, 20 years ago
we probably couldn't
have even walked into.
You know, I'm part of that story now.
My clients are a part of that story now.
We're part of the history of this place.
We're a part of its legacy,
and that's
that's really cool.
(slow jazz music)